kansas city i can't thank you enough for
another great weekend sold out shows
saturday night the comedy club of kansas
city great club thank you so much
uh the night pants nation tour continues
vancouver i will be there february 17th
through the 19th nashville one night
only thursday march 3rd and lexington
kentucky i will be there friday and
saturday march 4th
and 5th tickets to all dates
are available on
ryansickler.com get yours today
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i am ryan sickler ryan sickler
on all social media ryan sickler.com
come check me out on tour on the night
pants nation tour that is all tickets
are available ryanstickler.com
uh vancouver february
let me say that again hold on
vancouver i said vancouver vancouver
february 17th through the 19th nashville
march 4th and lexington kentucky march
5th
and the 6th all right if you are
watching the show please hit that
subscribe on your youtube help us all
out over there and for the patreon i got
to tell you look man i love my job and i
have you all to thank for that this show
the honeydew with y'all
is just it's some of my favorite [ __ ]
ever like sitting and listening to you
guys highlight your low lights is some
of my
just
i can't even tell i go i go home i start
telling people like i talked to this guy
today fell off a cliff and was paralyzed
spent the night in the wilderness like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i'm
like man it's five bucks a month all
right if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free and you get the
honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right we're keeping
it five bucks so if you or someone you
know has that story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com and hopefully we'll get to do
an episode together all right that's the
news right there and you guys know what
we do over here we highlight the low
lights these are the stories behind the
storytellers i'm very excited to have
this guest on today first time here on
the do ladies and gentlemen please
welcome brian sipps and welcome to the
honeydew brock it's me
thank you for being here my friend we've
been trying to make this happen for a
while yeah yeah man yeah it's kind of
you know you like ships in the night and
[ __ ] you know well before we get into
anything please promote plug everything
please the special all that stuff get
your phone get it all check me out uh
netflix uh season three to standups
episode one that's me
um i'm also gonna be in vancouver
dagon
[Music]
oh actually that just got moved
right you you loved the jfl you were
doing no it's just
stand up so nevermind check that out
i'll be the irvine improv on february
9th ontario improv on february 10th
madison wisconsin
february 24th through the 26th
bakersfield on the 5th
and
philly punchline april 8th through the
10th so um and then netflix the netflix
festival was the end of april it's all
on my i'm bs comedian on all social
platforms bs comedian yeah bs comedian
my link tree is right there for the
tickets so go do that all right
yeah congrats on everything i was saying
earlier like i met you
that's years ago now in san diego seven
eight years ago yeah and we were
backstage in that tiny little ass green
room and i just saw i sat and watched
you and i was like dude what'd i tell
you i was like you got it yeah get your
ass up to la you got it look at you good
for you dude yeah man it's coming well
i'm glad to have you here um i wanted to
get into
talking about your life story cause um
you told me you're a foster kid twice
yeah so let's go back to the beginning
here you're originally from dc is that
right i was born in dc all right take us
through a little bit of brian simpson's
early years yeah born in dc
uh
live with my mom and you know so
actually what's so funny is i've
recently found out that my mom was also
a foster kid i was that right and her
mom was a foster kid also it runs in the
family some
you know and so it was like you know
this weird [ __ ] where like your parents
would just drop a nugget on you
you know when they 60 and you'd be like
what the [ __ ] you ain't never say that
about that no but uh
but no i was i was living with my mom i
was living with my
mom and her mom okay in dc
and my my grandmother liked to date
uh abusive men you know my mom just
couldn't take the [ __ ] no more she ended
up burning one of the [ __ ] with
an iron
really your mom did how old was she
like like teenagers um yeah she was like
well i think she was 18 at the time
and she just got cuz the dudes would
never do nothing to her
because that that's the that's that's
the line right there for my grandma like
don't [ __ ] with my kids but she just got
tired of
you know waking up and seeing swollen
eyes and swollen jaws you know she was
like you touched my mother one more
[ __ ] time
and dude thought she was playing my
mother ain't for play you know and she
did it she burned that [ __ ] and
it was that she just got tired of it and
she couldn't
i think she couldn't afford to take us
with her uh-huh so she left us there
okay so you're with your grandma so i'm
with my brother who's us you say us
me and my older brother okay and
so
then um we we had an aunt that lived
upstairs
it's your mom's sister my mom sister in
the same building and she had kids of
her own you know and we
um
and i don't know who what it is because
he nothing too is like my grandmother
would get into it with people you know
what i'm saying like the slightest sign
of disrespect
and give me an example what do you
remember
like like what sticks out you seeing
like grandmother [ __ ] around like what's
the one where you're like okay
like
you know like one time i um my
grandfather you know who you know she
told him hey
[ __ ] you come by this house one
more time
and it's gonna be some [ __ ] you know he
thought she was playing and she went and
put some daggone uh
oatmeal on the stove
heated it up real nice yep soon as he
walked in the door put through that [ __ ]
on his head no hot oatmeal yeah
you know i mean like she she's on that
kind of like she's one of those people
where it's like if she say if she tell
you she's gonna do that she's gonna do
something yeah it's happening
yeah
yeah so it's one of those type of deals
and
holy [ __ ] okay so so i don't know if she
got into it with a neighbor or what it
was but somebody
uh called the authorities and said to me
and my brother was home by ourselves
which we were because everybody was like
kids back then this is the 80s right so
our school was yeah what year are you
born i was born in 82 okay so our school
was right across the street went to
martial king elementary
and
you know so we would walk home and we'd
be home for maybe three hours by
ourselves and it was it was nothing all
the kids in the neighborhood did that so
i don't know who was the snitch
um but they called the cops and then
and my dumb ass cause i got to talk all
the time
don't open the door
you know even for me don't open the door
for nobody you know
but they had just started this thing in
the schools where the cops were coming
to school with like candy and [ __ ] and
it would be like officer friendly
officer friendly dude that's creepy as
[ __ ] right here the whole
message is don't take candy from
strangers yeah but not but then the plot
of cops i guess and they was officer
friendly so every officer was officer
friendly which is something else i
didn't put together at that time
but they all said their names was
officer friendly you know and it was
that kind of [ __ ] and the cop knocked on
the door and my and i remember my
brother standing right here like looking
at me like don't you [ __ ]
you know but it was like it's officer
friendly and i'm like well
so i opened the door
and they took us down to the police
station and and all i remember is we
sitting there eating pizza at the police
station and all i remember is my
grandmother coming in that [ __ ]
on ten
just like
pouring off because she because it was
one of the things where it was like
everybody kids at home be home by the
way we were yeah yeah it's like we
poured everybody so she was just like
why y'all [ __ ] with my fam you know
it was that kind of thing they it got to
the point where like they were like
ma'am
we're gonna we won't have to sit you
back in the cell back there you know and
she calmed down she took us home
but that was a whole other thing and
then maybe like did you ever find out
who did that did she ever find out no
who did she suspect
i don't know who she suspected
me
i think maybe she suspected it was our
aunt oh really family i'm thinking
neighbor you're thinking family member
huh well cause that's what we ended up
with because she was upstairs yeah like
two weeks later we ended up upstairs
living upstairs and where's grandma
still downstairs but she just had to go
up there and be supervised upstairs now
nah she was just like
you know
i don't know she just wasn't around you
know okay i think she felt betrayed or
she i don't know what it was
but
um but then you know obviously
it's hard to go from having two kids to
having four kids overnight you know i
mean so
our auntie was like well i can't afford
to do this and this and that and
so my my older brother and i we have
different dads
so his dad's mom
was already a foster parent
and you know in the state is like
looking at chops at that [ __ ] because
they they want to put you with family
you know they try to put you with family
first before they even put you in a home
but a family that's already at home they
went for that
so but i did not know this
you know what i'm saying you didn't know
which part that they want to put you in
a home or to his mom i don't know we was
going to a home i see so this is this is
how old are you right at this moment at
this point i'm six oh yeah yeah maybe
going on okay seven sure you know what i
mean but
but i remember
i remember going uh i remember them
going y'all going to paw's house for
christmas
so
you know it was that was that's dope
because
because even though i could be a bit
much around the holidays she was cheery
everybody getting gifts she could cook
like a [ __ ] she lived in the
suburbs so i was like oh we going we
leaving the hood we're going to the
suburbs we have we're going to have a
good ass christmas good ass meal you
know it's a it's mad kids suburbs of
maryland or virginia suburbs of maryland
okay
and uh this was temple hills which maybe
it's not even a good neighborhood no
more you know [ __ ] change up so fast now
but but we go over there and then and
then it got to the point where you know
we were there for maybe a week
you know we got a little gifts and [ __ ]
everybody had nintendo's they had cable
look at your eyes like yeah bro
cause we handled them okay well they got
cable over there but after about a week
the simplest [ __ ] after about a week
it's like
it was like all right now
you know the the holiday cheer starting
to wear the [ __ ] off everybody's
starting to beat themselves and i'm
ready to go to [ __ ] home you know what i
mean and
um and then i got into it with one of
the other kids
you know and i was like well [ __ ] you
then [ __ ] because i'm going home so i
ain't got well you ain't gotta worry
about it you know what i mean she was
like what you talking about y'all live
here like what
you got moved in and you didn't even
know i didn't know i didn't know you're
the only one i was the only one that
didn't know and that man
that feeling you tell me about it that's
that that is that
that activated something because i think
it's cause we're here and it gives me
action because when you're that young
you don't have the words
right for your vocabulary emotional
communicate that but it was betrayal i
felt betrayed and i know how to say it
by who
you know i think at the time i didn't
identify the person but it was my
as i got older i realized it was my aunt
yeah i felt betrayed because i'm like
how come you didn't trust me
with the knowledge that this is what was
gonna happen
you know what i mean because a lot of
times as adults you tell yourself that
you ain't that you're not saying [ __ ] to
your kids for them
you're saying you're telling yourself
that you're protecting them but in
reality you're protecting yourself now
did your older brother know
i don't think he i think he knew before
i did
okay
but but everybody at that house knew you
all were coming to live there yeah
everybody's at the house when i was
gonna live here and hurry a week slips
by without it coming out and my our kids
knew we was going
you know what i mean i was the last one
to know and i was pissed about it
you know what i mean and it informed it
just it just painted it just i stopped
trusting adults right then you know i'm
just like [ __ ] all y'all maybe it wasn't
right at the exact moment but it just
put me it was like i went from trusting
all the adults in my family completely
to like
questioning them i mean look it makes
sense when you can't trust the adults in
the family
you sure as hell gonna have a difficult
time trusting the ones outside the
family yeah what what was this what i
couldn't wrap my head around is like why
don't they trust me why didn't they you
know what i mean right and it takes a
while to
unlock all of that brian i can't tell
you how many relatives my grandma
everybody will tell you when you get
older guess what they're all dead
yeah
and um
and so anyway so then
i think that lasted i think i was there
the longest so in is that technically
that was the foster home you were
talking about yeah okay that was the
first was the first one all right yeah
there and there were maybe
there was there were a lot of kids there
there was like
you know
there were maybe nine kids there
all right so from doing this show and
talking to people who've been in foster
care i understand that there's it's a
system and these parents also get a
check and sometimes the kid is just a
check they don't really look after you
are you being cared for are you really
being oh yeah okay the thing is
to be honest with you most of the homes
i were in
were
you know very few of them that i feel
like were like warehousing kids because
here's the truth of the matter is it
ain't that big of a check
i never thought so either because i have
a child i'm like that ain't [ __ ] no no
it's not that big of a check and so for
you for you to have for you to be on
that you'd have to be
you know literally like stuffing kids on
top of each other you know you'd have to
have six kids in a room and multiple
rooms for you to be like just doing it
for money
i don't think most k most
parents were doing that um
no but then what tell me this what is
the goal of
foster care is it the hopes i know i
know but is it the hopes that the their
parent gets
right and then they can go back to their
families or is it um
let's
educate them on life here in this home
so that when they go off they're okay or
is it both does it depend on the parent
you know like you said you were in twice
and eventually you got out is that
because you were 18 and got out or
because you went back home to a parent
because i was because i was 18. okay so
you never did your mom never came back
at like 12 or 15 and got you well she
couldn't she because why because when
she came back because
because so i stayed in that home for
until i was 11. okay
and
and then my father came okay back and
got me up all right so now you're with
dad now with that but i'm separated from
my brother because we have different
dads right right and
it was something to do with the fact
that like in order for him to take sole
custody
they had to take her parental rights in
absentia
you know because they didn't know where
she was right
and
so when she came so she was gone no one
knew where she was no oh okay so she
came back like a year after that
but she don't have the parental rights
so she can't take you okay you know what
i mean so now you're with dad for how
long
for two years and what's that like
because you're 11. you're old enough to
remember [ __ ] like that now like what's
he like as a parent like what was it
like um well see me and my dad always
had a weird relationship because
you know i think it was more my
stepmother that was like you got to go
get your son
and he was more like i got my life
because again it's like having an extra
kid it's like something like can you
imagine somebody dropping an extra kid
on you right now
you know what it's like we got a puppy
and i can't take it and that
motherfucker's 11.
right so he don't got no respect for you
he ain't got you know what i mean it's
that kind of thing it was like
so me and him always had that weird
relationship it was always like this
it was like you know i look i recognize
that your dad and you recognize him but
also [ __ ] you you know it was that kind
of energy
um
but i got into it mostly with my stepmom
like and when one time the [ __ ] came to
a head and they're like yo you got you
gotta get the [ __ ] out over what what
are you fighting over i don't even
remember i remember i don't remember
what the exact fight was over oh you
know actually i do remember i remember
because we we bought a house
and uh
and my room was in the basement
and my brother my brother and sister so
they already have two kids my brother
and sister and uh
and they had bedrooms and my room was in
the basement which i thought was cool at
first
but
the [ __ ] bugs and [ __ ] would come out
you know what i mean it was like and i
just i just i can't do it i can't i
can't deal with it and so i used to uh
i used to drag my mattress upstairs
and sleep in the living room
every night you'd be dragging up yeah
and i would wake up early before
everybody and drag it back down in the
basement
yeah and so [ __ ] came to her head she
caught me one time
and she was like yeah don't do that [ __ ]
you know and then
fast forward this was like around
christmas time it's like over christmas
and uh
and my dad had asked us all what we
wanted for christmas
and
my uh my brother and sister were like we
want tvs and i was like i don't want a
tv i want a computer
you know and he got them both like two
19-inch tvs
and i'm sitting here opening up my
computer and it's a daggone
um it's like a child's computer it's
like a speaking spell
yeah
it
oh this is a prank
right no it was not a prank it was not a
prank this is texas
i was so pissed i went down i didn't
come back out the basement for the whole
christmas break i had my own bathroom
yeah i was so mad and then
it was time to go back to school
and i remember it was time to go back to
school and i uh
and i then i had dragged my uh my
mattress back up a little and i got
caught again
and it would turn into this big old
fighting ball and i was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] blah blah and then that was a wrap
and i ended up going on the street to
live with my cousin and i got into a
fight with her and i ended up going back
and living with
my brother's grandmother again okay but
this time not as a foster kid this time
it was like an adult now no i'm not an
adult i'm not 18 at this point no no no
this is all enough that's when you got
out got you guys no this is like i'm
like 12. okay at this time well 13.
and uh so you're bouncing around
everywhere yeah how are your grades [ __ ]
grades
i wasn't thinking about that [ __ ] at all
i didn't like it was any adult give it a
[ __ ] either oh yeah
they try to hit me with the uh you need
to apply yourself and all that and i'm
like [ __ ] you don't got no idea what
you're talking about
you know what i mean
because i remember what you said [ __ ]
which makes me laugh because it's a
woman at least that took the time to say
yeah they don't dude
the thing is i wasn't i didn't say [ __ ]
no i know but i'm saying the reason you
responded was because there were women
that at least stepped up i'm saying guys
aren't saying [ __ ] like that doesn't
look good like you need to buy it some
lady at least it was always it was
always women
begging me to try
and i was just like [ __ ] you that was
that's how i felt you know
and uh
and i remember
i i got into it again with my um
stepmom well no with my bro something so
i'm back i got into my brother and then
i got and then i got into one of the
other kids there
why what are you fighting about
does it go back to that fire that got
lit when you were betrayed man no it was
just it was just i i had this tremendous
feeling of like unfairness and when i
felt like something was unfair like you
just couldn't tell me [ __ ]
you know what i mean it was like i
invisible i demanded that's right i was
like i demanded something
that somebody listened to my my concerns
you know what i mean it was like i just
i wasn't a kid that you could just be
like
because i said so that wasn't enough for
me
it had to make sense to me you know and
a lot of adults
back then they wouldn't they weren't
taking the time to do that
i don't got time to be explaining [ __ ]
to no children you know
so that's really what it all stemmed
from and then
my my by that time my step my uh my
stepmother and my father had gotten
divorced or at least separated and i
went back and lived with my dad by
myself
right and all of this happened in like a
like a year and a half
it's a lot yeah and then
my dad and then uh
i'll never forget man
my dad had this wow [ __ ] where like
because because again me and him have
always had this distance you know what i
mean and so
um
in in
my dad he wasn't no lazy [ __ ]
you know i mean he he always worked two
three jobs to send us a net
and so he would always be gone like he
would get up at
you know he would he would get up at
like eight leave the house and not come
back until like
six in the morning you know sleep for a
couple hours get up and go back you know
what i mean and the thing is i wasn't
allowed to leave the house if he wasn't
home because he knew i'm mischievous you
know i'm gonna do what i want yeah so i
was just always in the [ __ ] house you
know and
and i remember he he had these uh
he started he started doing this little
thing where he would he would like put a
little put a piece of paper up in his
door
so he could tell if i went in there
and i cracked that system real quick
and so you crack that one i would just
do i would just do it back i was like
dude take it out and put it back i was
like well
however he doing it i can do it right
because he's leaving the room so then he
just straight up started locking the
door like he bought a lock and put it on
the door what's in there and he's
worried about you [ __ ] i don't even
know but but the thing is i wouldn't
have gave a [ __ ] if he hadn't locked the
door right that's what i'm saying he's
making you yeah so
i learned how to learn how to break in
there with a credit card
me too i was good at the credit
and uh
and then i remember uh
he had he had this this big ass
jar of chocolates
that
i don't know if it was for his hoes or
what but
yeah hey that taco's from my house
yeah it was like it was or sephora
specific oh but but it was like it was
like um but he kept that [ __ ] locked
behind the lock door too right it was on
top of his dresser but but it had um it
was like you know those jars that like
the uh like where you would get the
assorted popcorn in and [ __ ] yeah and it
had the it had the shrink wrap seal
around just around the top third of the
jar so i learned
yeah so i learned
yeah i learned how to i learned how to
twist the plastic and the top at the
same time
and
you would and i was disciplined with it
you know i would eat i would eat one of
the [ __ ] i would just eat one
and but but
you know but you know when you're that
old
even that's your most clever you're not
as clever as you think yeah right you're
and so one day it just got to the point
where even though i had taken my time
after a couple of months it was apparent
that somebody was eating these
chocolates you know what i'm saying yeah
and my father came on one day he was
like what the [ __ ]
he came home he's like yo what and i'm
i'll never forget i'm sitting there
watching tv
and the thing is we it was it wasn't it
wasn't uncommon for us to not speak at
all you know because that's the thing
his schedule was he would leave in the
morning
right after i left for school
and he and he went i wouldn't see him
again until the morning when you latch
key you come home let yourself yeah you
wouldn't see him again but every once in
a blue moon he would come home at some
random [ __ ] time you know it's like
anything like he told me his schedule
you know what i'm saying so this is one
of those times he came home at a random
[ __ ] time
and i'm sitting there at night i'm
watching tv
because i was obsessed with star trek
because that's all that was on you know
because when you have cable
and
and uh
and he goes
you been in these [ __ ] chocolates
i was like nah and he was like then what
the [ __ ] happened to him there
and i don't know what came over me
but but i could have just been like i
don't know which would have still been a
lie
but i said
i don't know [ __ ] like like like i said
it i said it like what you're trying to
do about it you know what i'm saying
which was a mistake like the moment the
moment the words came on my lips i was
like what why did you say it like that
right like where did that come from
bruh and i'll never know
within us
within a second he had yelped me up off
because like
because
here's the other side two or two is you
gotta understand he's back here behind
me yeah yeah so so
you just threw it over yeah yeah i just
threw it over my shoulder and went back
to watching tv like like like i have
body guards or something
and i and i never again i went to good
i would i was eating like a tv dinner or
something
and that bite never made it in my mouth
it was like yeah
i
got yoked up from my on the couch
and like i said and that was the second
time i went into foster exactly
that oh yeah that night was the last
night that i was
because
because he yoked me up against the wall
and i could tell like holy [ __ ]
you are crazy for saying that even if
you have a good parent they're gonna
snack oh man and i could tell like he
didn't want to hurt me
but he wanted me to he wanted me to know
that he could you know
it was that kind of thing
it was hurting him to like hold me up
against the wall like man what
you about to make me [ __ ] [ __ ] you up
you know what i mean and i was like and
then and man but man i just had a i had
a spirit in me that day man and i was
like
and i was like well it was like you know
i came i can't beat you
but you got to go to sleep
i said that to him you said that yeah
and that's man you doubled down yeah he
because i'm telling you man i wonder he
got ready here i go cause i told him
it just felt it just felt so unfair man
cause i was like why you you don't give
a [ __ ] what i do no other time of the
day [ __ ] you don't never talk to
me you don't see me never
you know what i mean and and and now and
it's like man you get to come home and
disciplinary like what like [ __ ] you
like that's that's what i was feeling
you know i ain't understand what it was
like to be a parent and be working three
jobs and have to worry about your kid
you know i ain't understand all that i
didn't give a [ __ ] either you know even
if i understood i probably wouldn't have
cared but i was just like yeah you don't
get to come home and and boss me up you
know and
it's like yeah go to sleep i dare you it
was that kind of thing and so he called
the cops the cops yeah how old are you
i'm
15 like
i'm probably 13. and he called the cops
on you
his 13 year old son yeah because what
else could he have did so what happens
to a 13 year old when his dad calls the
cops on them for throwing
threatening them well well well okay
well i felt i i jumped i jumped ahead of
schedule
first he called my first he called his
my cousin from up from down the street
and she showed up like first he called
family and they showed up and i was like
[ __ ] all y'all too you know what i mean
it was that kind of thing
and it was like well
you know about in the cops the cops are
on the way and the cops show up and i'm
like [ __ ] y'all
you know
yeah yeah i i had i was and i remember
i'll never forget it was it was two it
was two cops was a male and a female
and the and the female was trying to
tell me like hey hey hey hey
you but you need to stop talking to my
partner
because
because this could go real bad for you
like stop talking to him like that and
i'm like [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you but
this time i'm a sandbitch
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah
and anyway they dropped me off at uh
i dropped you off
yeah yeah where you where'd they take
you did they cuff you
they did not cuff okay they uh well
maybe they did i don't actually remember
you went you went peacefully at the end
of that
i did okay yeah i did i did so you what
you sit in the back of the car and they
drop you where they dropped me at the um
at the it was like the juvenile
detention center oh so you're going to
it now have you ever been there before i
was there there no that was your first
time that's my first time are you scared
do you even know where you're going when
you're in this car i don't even know
what nope i have no idea why are you so
angry are you are you scared
um
i mean 13 years old being put into a
detention center away from everybody you
know does it sound good
because everyone that you should love
and trust has been betrayed you or is it
[ __ ] terrifying
i don't know because i i don't remember
being scared i just remember
just being like whatever you know i
didn't care you know
do how much of that do you remember
going in that place i don't you don't
because it wasn't for that long it was
like are you in a cell a room no i'm in
a big ass um
i don't know almost like a squad bay
like a hall like a yeah like a military
uh barracks okay and there's like
i don't know maybe 20 beds and 20 dudes
okay
and i remember the social worker telling
me like
this is just temporary
blah blah blah blah because you haven't
like committed a crime
you know so this is just temporary
because there's no way else to put you
right okay and i think i was there for
maybe like a week or two damn okay and
i'm just trying not to get into no
fights
while i was there
um and
and then they found me then they found
me for a
um like a dope home and i remember her
the lady pulling up to this house who
was this lady this the social worker
lady
and she wasn't my she was i mean the
place you're going the family oh yeah
well that's what i'm saying i pull up to
this family and i was like whoa
these so these [ __ ] live lived
in the burbs you know what i'm saying
like yeah like where like rockville
montgomery county no this was suitland
okay i don't know that oh no they so
they lived in siouxland and they pull up
and man and me and i these [ __ ]
got
christmas decorations
like i never seen
like
rudolph and
[ __ ] blinking and bla and i was like
holy [ __ ] like this is the house and she
was like no no no
it's the house right next to it
if it wasn't [ __ ] on that house
i was like okay
but it was cool though that lady so this
she was probably the best foster mother
mental health has definitely become a
part of the global conversation
especially recently uh after what a
worldwide pandemic we've got fentanyl
you talk about all of it all right new
mood is here to guide you to mental
wellness and give you the tools you need
to tackle stress so you'll feel
empowered to take on whatever life
throws at you all right they have a
team of dedicated coaches so you have a
support system helping you and my
favorite thing about it is that it's
literally a step-by-step guide to help
manage your mental wellness and you can
do it at your own pace all right you can
arm yourself with the knowledge and
skills for happiness and all you need is
10 minutes a day all right it's an app
so it's there for you
anytime anywhere all right worry less
and feel happier okay you can sign up
right now for your trial at noom.com
honeydew that's n
o o m
dot com slash honeydew start your trial
today take care of your mental health
everyone's always worried about their
physical health and hitting the gym and
everything and mental health is
absolutely just as important all right
take care of yourself today again that's
n o o m dot com slash honeydew now let's
get back to the duke okay now what kind
of lady is this why is this lady looking
for a 13 year old boy
how does she find you why she pick you i
mean i think i think you know they call
them and they go hey this is the thing
this is what's wrong with this kid
do you got room what do you know what
they classified you as just anger
i don't know what they classify me at at
that point
but i do know that
that if you keep moving
you get classified as a problem child
and then you can only go to you like the
antonio brown and the foster exactly
exactly so i wasn't i wasn't a problem
child yet okay yeah all right no but
this lady would she but she was big on
like young black men and taking them and
turning them into a mint okay and like
you know teaching you how to you know
make your best she's a black lady yeah
big time make your bed earn your clothes
you know go to church this this kind of
thing
and uh
and uh she's still alive man she still
looked young i was gonna ask do you do
you keep in touch with her or let her
know what you're doing yeah yeah she
know you have your netflix
i haven't talked to her since dad but um
i will want to i'm gonna call her soon
you should but uh i don't even man
i don't know what i don't know what
she's gonna say about it
what can she say she helped all the
profanity um no but she she remember she
would she was the most disciplined lady
i ever knew she would fast every month
really every month for a week she would
fast was it just a health thing or was
that religious i think it was just i
think it was just a discipline thing wow
yeah she still looks young maybe
something today
you know and she um
so how many guys were in the house when
you were there at a time would you say
there were four of us four okay yeah all
from various issues
uh and are you guys working to help her
and her home or does everybody have
their own thing going on outside the
home like are you up keeping the place
or is this just a lady taking like are
there other chores yes oh yeah okay
there's chores in there she's like mo
you said suburbs there yard you got to
take care of leaves you have to rake
[ __ ] like that you gotta do all that in
fact not only do you matter in fact you
gotta put up the christmas decorations
no it wasn't no christmas decorations it
was not for the neighbors oh no but it
was like you gotta go you gotta go
shovel the neighbor's driveway you gotta
go do all that too yeah and it was like
um but it was cool for a minute and i
and i remember i got into it one of the
other kids again
why
because i was i was the youngest one man
in in in
it
and i and he was just such a bully dog
and i couldn't and i remember i was so
at this point i like i remember i was
sitting on the stairs crying one time
and she was like what's wrong with you
and i was like
i was like he won't stop [ __ ] with me
she was like then punch his ass in the
mouth she said that yeah
she was like i can't what you want me to
do i can't show up every time somebody
messes with you
and i was like
i bet that and i kicked him down the
stairs
it's way
different yeah cause i'm like cause i'm
like if i punch him in the middle i'm
paralyzed
no it was it was only like five stairs
but but i was just like because he was
bigger than me and i'm like he's gonna
whip my ass but if he gonna with my ass
i'm gonna make it worth it you know yeah
so i kicked them out instead
and uh and that turned into you know a
whole thing where they they were like
you know he need to be somewhere where
he ain't
got a fight you know so they moved me
and they moved me to another home
that but these two women were friends
i see okay you know and and in this home
this was probably like one of the lowest
points because this next home was in
another nice couple this is the only
home this is the first home i was in
where there was a father
all these homes so far as the first yeah
and
and what was that like
it was cool man did you like it did you
like having a male role model around was
he a positive male
role one you know what i'm saying he was
like uh
tell me about him what'd he do do you
remember what he did for a living or
um i think he was a real estate guy okay
was it funny was he what was he like he
was funny
he was very but he was very like no
nonsense
you know he's one of those dudes where
you where like he had to hit you or
threaten you you know just him being
disappointed would be like oh [ __ ] make
you feel you know what i'm saying it was
that kind of thing
and uh
he ended up passing away from uh
from uh
from some kind of cancer why you lived
with him yeah oh man yeah you saw that
yeah yeah yeah i mean i saw it when it
was like everything was fine right and
then hospital and then gone you know man
and
um
i mean what's that like that's the first
male positive male role model and he
just dies in front of you
oh no man you know i guess at the time i
was trying to act like it didn't bother
me
and that bothered some people in the
family
you know and then i was getting into it
with them you know it was a whole thing
um
but i remember the uh
this was the same place where there was
a
so one of the older kids had one of the
former kids that you had lived there
came and like left
a pistol there for the one of the older
other kids to watch
okay you know and he used to come he's
he was to [ __ ] with me with it all the
time like he would be like boom and he
uh
and i woke up one time and he was like
don't [ __ ] move don't move and i
thought somebody had broken the house
because i could feel the gun on me and
then they turned them like that on your
head
oh yeah and i was like and they turned
on the lights and it was them laughing
everybody laughing and [ __ ] i was like
all right i got you
you know and then one day he was like in
the shower getting ready for a date or
whatever and i [ __ ] got the pistol
and um
and i racked it one time
[Music]
no no no no i got the pistol and i
dropped the clip out because that's what
i saw him do
you know but i didn't know it was it was
one
went off you pulled the trigger yeah
yeah i pulled the trigger for sure and
it went off
did it hit anybody yeah hit him in the
stomach what you shot him in the stomach
while he was in the shower no it was
after he got out of the shower oh my god
but it was a 22
you know and that [ __ ] 20 it won't like
break vulnerable bounce around yeah
yeah man and that was
it man that [ __ ] was that was one of the
worst nights of my life what the [ __ ]
are you thinking right away
i i panicked you know what i'm saying
that he told me to call his friend
not 9-1-1 no right right he was like
call my call and call my friend and i
called his friend and his friend was
like what the [ __ ] don't listen to him
call 9-1-1 you know
but
um by then the neighbors had called
9-1-1 you know it was like all another
loud they heard it huh
yeah they heard it and is he screaming
is he yelling or is he is he holding it
together no he's going oh oh
is it bleeding out in front of you
you're seeing it it's bl it's bile it's
like green no
yeah and i and i don't at the time i
didn't know
i didn't know that that was bad but i
knew it was like yeah i mean if
and who's home with you just youtube
it's just us
and i remember the the the when they
when the ambulance and then finally
showed up by the time the ambulance got
there
moms was back already too with all the
kids they don't forget where they had
gone
and uh
and i remember her like looking at me
like
like what the [ __ ] is going on and i had
no answers for her you know what i'm
saying yeah and this lady was so sweet
man it was like i ain't wish nothing
like this on her man because i not like
looking like it hurts more now looking
back on it because
because now as an adult i know how hard
it is to raise children and and all the
little emergencies that could pop up
that you know what i mean and sometimes
it should just be too much
you know yeah and no offense she's got
four difficult children
yeah well this is a new lady
yeah yeah yeah well at this time how
many kids are somehow no she's got three
kids three okay yeah but she just lost
her husband right he's died he's dead
now like shit's gone it's that kind of
[ __ ] and i remember um well what happens
to this kid they come take him
so they come take them
they and when they take him to the house
are you freaking out that this kid could
die and now you're gonna be going away
for murder or like
because the ambulance is there the
paramedics are there
and they they can't go in the house
they can't go in the house until the
house is clear until the cops clear the
house
because
i didn't tell them the truth
what did you tell them i told them
somebody came somebody ran in and shot
them somebody
yeah
okay so they know that something's weird
yeah no well that was no they took me at
my word and was like oh
yeah and so
but i'm sitting there like i know i've
lied because he told me a lot like i'm
trying not to get the wrong people in
trouble or wrong people names involved
and but they can't go in until they know
ain't nobody in there you know what i
mean but but he's sitting right over
right over
right through the window dying you know
it's that kind of so i was freaking out
from that
and they take me to the police station
and they like and this and at the time i
thought this dude had just like um you
know to do from um
from uh what's the journey with the
irish dudes
um the classic
movie with the irish brothers
um and they
and they like pray before they kill you
and [ __ ] you know somehow
is it boondock scene boondock saints yes
you know willem dafoe
i'm thinking he just willing to follow
me
because
he basically this cop sat down and he
was like look so this is what i think
happened and he was like
he was like i think there was a gun in
the house
you were playing with the gun
it went off
and you panicked
and this this and that
and i'm like and i'm in my mind i'm like
[ __ ] he's right [ __ ]
but i still try to log in i'm like well
he's like listen listen
you called
somebody else
when everybody else was calling the
police
so
so either it was an accident
and
you panicked or you it was on purpose
and you tried to cover it up
so which which one is going to be it was
that kind of [ __ ]
yeah we went anyway they took me out at
home
and i actually actually ended up going
back to the previous what happened to
the kid
i don't know at this point okay i don't
know all right all right i'm not allowed
to contact them or him okay so in fact i
remember
i mean i skipped ahead a lot
but i as i was sitting in the hospital
with you know with them
it was like
[ __ ] didn't add up and and people in the
family were slowly starting to like
figure it out figure out that like i
wasn't telling the truth and it started
getting kind of hostile you know what i
mean yeah yeah i bet yeah and uh
so who takes you in knowing that you
just shot somebody who's that parent i
went back to the previous house ah they
took you back yeah i was i was just
there temporarily until they found
somewhere else okay okay
and uh
and uh
and and then
i forget where the [ __ ] ended up
happening after that but i um
i ended up now i'm a problem child
obviously and now officially yeah yeah
you got a weapon right so now i'm now i
end up going to this house way over in
um
in uh
what the [ __ ] is it like like over there
on riggs road you know somehow
it's like a giant over there what is
that is that is that hyattsville i love
hearing giant yeah yeah but but i but
anyway i ended up going to another house
and and this house is like everybody
[ __ ] up in here it's probably like six
kids and they're and all of them are way
worse off than me you know what i'm
saying there's people that have been
through some [ __ ] you know they people
that have been sold and kidnapped and
some of [ __ ] you know
and
and but this house was talk it was crazy
you know and um
without getting too much into it i just
um i think i stayed here for the longest
time though do you have your own room or
you always sharing always sharing always
always never have privacy never had my
own room um
and um
and i ended up
getting into it with the father at this
house
because
we used to wake up we used to wake up
and do this paper route with him like we
would wake up like four in the morning
go sort these papers toss them blah blah
blah and i know i was
these are our chores blah blah blah and
then i found out
you know how much money he was making of
it and he wasn't and so one day i was
like hey i need this or that for school
and he was like [ __ ] out of here what
like all this work we do for you you
don't give us nothing i'm asking you for
something i need [ __ ] you then so the
next day he he did the call
and tried to wake everybody up to come
help him and i didn't come
you know
and it turned into another thing i was
like defiant you know
and uh and i ended up going to this
group home
that was way out in i want to say anne
arundel county
and i got caught
um
this is this is the first school i went
to like you could leave school
for lunch and i got caught smoking weed
in the woods these [ __ ] had
cameras in the woods
yeah
that's early to be having cameras in the
woods yeah this is high school they were
ready yeah they had cameras in the woods
and they dagger on how'd they catch it
what they called you in
well they they were they were watching
us
they were watching us smoke but i was
the only one that they had pictures of
with the blunts on my mouth and for
whatever reason just by chance we were
done smoking we when we walked when we
got out came out the other side of the
woods they were waiting for us right and
it just so happened that they couldn't
find the blunt and they couldn't find
the wheat and it was in my pocket
okay but they patted us down a whole
bunch of times and they couldn't find
another weed but they had pictures of me
smoking
and they were trying to get me to snitch
on everybody else
and i didn't and
and i'll never forget the lady being
like uh because the kid because the bad
ass kid who was the bad influence and he
was a bad influence
but she was like why are you protecting
this [ __ ] this and that
and that's when i got on the principal
because i was like so i skipped this
part when i first got to the school
i had i had like made up my mind like
okay this is my last chance by this time
i'm like 16 or 17
and i'm telling her like look
i get into this this math class and i'm
like hey
i don't know how to use this [ __ ]
calculator you know i mean i don't even
know what this curriculum is but like
can you give me some extra worksheets or
some [ __ ]
and she's like nah
no i know i don't think you understand
like i'm here through no fault of my own
like i'm a foster kid
and
this is a new curriculum there's a whole
other school district i don't know
what's going on she was like i don't
care
and so and i complained and nobody did
anything and so now i'm sitting in the
principal's office and she's trying to
talk about the future blah blah blah
blah and stop protecting this battle i
was like why are you protecting that
teacher that won't [ __ ] teach me
that was a wrap there
and um ended up going back to that same
to the previous house
and then i ended up going back to live
with my stepmother
god damn dude you're just bouncing yeah
and then i and then i that's when i
joined the marine corps because i was
like man [ __ ] all of this so even then
you're asleep with a bunch of people too
what
what age did you finally have your own
room for the first and only time where
you're able to shut a door where just
you went to bed in it how old were you
i was
26 damn
yeah i'm 39 now 26
and i've never had my own place ever no
so i was 36 i might well i was about to
change this year obviously but yeah
never had my own room before i was 26
the closest you really got to peace and
quiet was
probably the time you live with your dad
when you wouldn't see him up until
he whooped your ass
okay yeah you know you know what yeah i
had my own room there i was gonna say
what i'm saying you spent a lot of time
alone so you probably have peace and
quiet at least for a little bit there
yeah
so i hear all this this anger and this
rage and everything have you done
therapy have you really looked at where
where it comes from is it that moment
is it the [ __ ] moment they told you
you live here that's
is that really it yeah that's where
that's where it all began yeah it was
that moment it just uh it was like that
moment of like this isn't just this is
unjust you know so how do you keep it in
check now
um i just stay away from things that
stress me out
you know i mean i mean i've i've done a
lot of like meditating and
cognitive behavioral therapy and that
sort of thing so i
i don't i don't just go off no more you
know it's still a lot of anger in me but
i keep it
you know plus i think it has something
to do too like you know once you start
pushing 40
you know you got to have other problem
solving skills other than i'll [ __ ] you
up
sooner or later you're going to lose a
lot of those right
if you're still fighting in your 40s
last thing i want to be is like that
old-ass drunk ass uncle that's always
getting knocked out of you at the
function yeah yeah so
i just learned once i learned once i
learned like oh you got the gift to gab
you know you should be able to talk your
way in and out of things
all right so
look i go back to my father died at 16
so i haven't had parents
since 16 on and you obviously worry
about your mom my mom left our family
before that we reconnected just a few
years ago i don't know but yeah so i
i've been on my own live with my
grandmother for a minute before she
dropped dead in front of us but on my
own since so
you seem to i mean i know there were
people in your life but you didn't have
parents really that were there what
about your mom through all this are you
are you seeing her at all during any of
this are you getting to spend time with
her get to know her yeah i mean i'm i'm
i'm uh
i'm contacting her to some degree but
at this point
you know it's all really dependent on
the foster parents and whether they were
allowed oh so that's a permission thing
they they don't have to let your
biological parents no contact because
she's lost her right ah i didn't know
that yeah once you once you're gone for
so long they legally are your guy uh
what do they say your legal guardian the
state is right okay yeah for sure so are
your parents still alive today yeah they
are and do you have a relationship with
them now yeah i have a good relationship
with both of them tell me about your
relationship with your dad like does he
come to see you do stand-up where's he
live now my dad has never seen me do
stand-up lives has he seen the netflix
special yeah did he like it oh yeah okay
good but not live where is he is he in
the still in the maryland dc area yeah i
think so yeah my uh my mom formed there
have you done dc or anything i haven't
no okay but my um but my mom did because
we filmed in new york my mom did come
down was that her first time seeing you
go up that's the first time seeing me
live yeah how was it for her oh it was
great she loved it oh yeah we cried we
did you know that's awesome she brought
her friends you know you know they were
like oh i do you really got a son you
know teasing her and she's like cause i
cuz i left because me and her i mean
because we didn't just start being close
we've been close for like
you know 12 13 years now how did you uh
reconnect and sort of start solidifying
that bond
um
we just did like we just
we i mean we never really lost
contact like that because i was always
in contact with my brother and my aunts
and aunties and all of that
but uh
but i think though as we got older the
more i realized that i'm like her
are you like her oh yeah in what ways
just just every just my our attitude the
way we
i mean she did beat that [ __ ] on
iron yeah yeah just the way
the way that we think the way that we
think for ourselves you know what i mean
it's that kind of work that kind of
thing yeah because i always get that
from other family members didn't do you
also see that parallel or did you
possibly in your grandmother i mean
maybe that's a survival thing through
the foster care system you said it was
you your mom and your grandmom right
right so i met listen i there's a chip
on your shoulder and there's one on mine
too there's one a lot of people but i
honestly i don't ever want it to go away
it's the it's the thing that's put me
right here and it's allowed me to still
survive on this [ __ ] rock and outer
space you know yeah and i don't mind
chiseling it a little bit but i don't
want that [ __ ] ever to go away
yeah because honestly it's not it it
isn't the issue that's right it's all
the other things you know it's like um
because you never want to fall into the
trap of going
because i know cleaning people that do
this where they go well now i have a
name
for what's wrong with me
and so the work's done right you know
now it's classified right yeah it's like
no man it's like it's like it's like the
doctor going you have cancer it's like
what what
that's not what yeah right that's not
the end okay you still got treatments
you know it's the diagnosis yeah that's
not the the treatment that's what it is
man it's just it's just constantly
working i mean it's just like
it's just like comedy it's like you know
you just got to keep doing that
repetition what about your dad when did
you guys decide to connect or how did
you reconnect
um i mean we never really lost contact
either even after that argument yeah i
mean we didn't speak for a while after
that but it was still like
it's because there's something about
it's something about your dad where you
was like you still want them to be proud
of you so somehow you know what i mean
and it was that it was like once he said
i'm proud of you
that
that and and that so happened to be at
the around the age
so i happened to be the age that he was
when he had you well no when we
fell out okay so when did he said i'm
proud of you to you about what
um just that i was just that i wasn't
quitting but i was like
um i'm uh i'm doing this you know this
is stand up and i was like i'm doing
this popping like i ain't
this is what i'm doing you know what i
mean he was like all right well i got
you like i'm proud of you you know don't
don't quit those four words that meant
everything yeah because i'm on because
because i always quit everything
you know what i mean like when my fact
when he dropped me off because he's the
one dropped me off
to the um
to the meps to join the marine corps
yeah and he was like
uh i'll see you in a couple weeks he
knew
he thought i was going to be hoped yeah
but he he was right too he if he hadn't
said that to me i would have quit you
would have oh yeah but it was just i was
like but i'm stubborn like i've
accomplished a lot of things out of
spite
so how many um years did you serve in
the marines i want to go back to that
five
good first of all thank you for your
service
and um what do you think did that help
you
the military did the military system put
structure and stuff in your life i mean
was it did it help you find you know
guidance or or you know how did it help
you i think i need i needed it for at
least a couple years i needed that and
how's a guy like you that's big on
principal getting yelled at by dudes
like that and not popping off you've had
a problem with every person of a figure
of authority all the way through up to
here that seems to be a challenge
um it kind of was
but i was in a unique situation
where you know even though there is
still a tremendous amount of unfairness
in the marine corps but at the same time
it's it's evenly distributed it's like
it's like oh you [ __ ] up everybody
paying the price i said it was that you
know and so you're not being picked on
or singled out no you're not being
picked on you're not well some people do
but that's a whole other thing some
people get picked on a single now but i
wasn't and and there's a
you never got in trouble with your mouth
in the marine corps oh yeah
oh yeah yeah i definitely did but but at
the same time it was like i was in a
situation where i was the only
um
there was a racial thing in my unit
before i got there
and so when i first got there everybody
was kind of like
walking on eggshells you know
and finally i was like hey everybody
just chill like
say whatever you want to say and i'm
gonna say whatever the [ __ ] i want to
say
you know and but i'm and i'm i'm better
at you better than you at that you know
what i mean and so it was i had a little
more leeway than everybody else when it
came to like speaking my mind or
speaking our mind you know and that's
when i started getting laughs that's how
that's kind of when i became funny is
that right yeah yeah and so i did every
now and then i would get in trouble for
little [ __ ] but i never got in no
official trouble okay i would you
weren't a problem child in the military
i was not i was not good at my job what
was your job in the military i was i was
a attack a tactical
air operations module repairment what is
that
we i just i fixed the box with a bunch
of computers in it but you weren't good
at it i mean i was good at that part but
i wasn't good at the marine part oh i
see you know the
being on time
and like that and like following all the
rules and all that
because that's what i'm talking about
yeah i wasn't i mean i would barely i
was just barely holding it together when
in in in there it wasn't for me which
was weird because everyone thought i
would be a lifer
i was like ain't no [ __ ] way i'll you
did five that's one extra why why'd you
do five it was just a job like because
the job because the job if you have a
job that makes you go to school for
longer than six months you got to do an
extra year and where were you san diego
where were you based i was stationed in
san diego yeah yeah dream dream place
and there's no and the thing is every
place outside of that is [ __ ] so
it's all downhill from there there's no
way i was going to sign up again yeah
nah nah
yeah then i and then i then i started
doing stan i mean i left there i went i
went i worked at intel for like a little
while and then i got fired from that
and then i went and then i went to the
pentagon for like did you really hear
some change yeah yeah i worked for
lockheed i was a subcontractor for
lockheed for the pentagon
and that was like a year some change
and then got laid off from that moved
back to san diego
started growing weed
did you really yeah i was not good at
that either
you quit that good good good yeah and i
started growing up going to school and
doing stand-up at the same time
and
and uh
and then i became like just real quickly
like i started i was the first employee
at the mad house that's what we met
and i got so much [ __ ] stage time
there you know that i got good fast yeah
and then i went and then you know
everybody kept telling me to move to l.a
move to l.a and one day i just did it
you know
and it was a mistake
was it why well it was just the way i
did it i didn't have a plan you know i
was just like because down there i had
set my life up in such a way that all i
could do was stand up mm-hmm
and
you know it was the way to save money or
a lot of that and that money i just
moved up here and my plan this is my
plan my plan was i'm just going to crash
on people's couches
until i find a place
and that was that's not a plan no no and
and at the same at the time i had severe
sleep apnea
and so
it's like you just burning bridges
because they because no matter how much
people love you or [ __ ] with you it's
like that ain't gonna fly
yeah you know yeah and i remember like
the first um
couch i stayed on i remember i was there
for like
a week or two and then somebody
was like yeah man we got a we got family
coming to visit so you know
you have to find some way to crash for
you know
the duration
i was like oh so when are they leaving
they're like we're not
sure
you know it was that kind of thing and
so i was i was literally on the street
for like two days
and i remember walking to the va and
here's here's the wild [ __ ] about
the biggest burden one of the biggest
burdens of being homeless besides the
obvious [ __ ]
is just having all your stuff
just wherever you go you got to have all
your [ __ ] yeah you ain't leaving it
anywhere it's just it's right
you got to carry all your [ __ ] or you
got to get a cart for all your [ __ ] and
then most of the places you need to go
inside of you got to leave your [ __ ]
outside
you know that was just it was just
something that i never had thought about
but i walked to the va and was like yo i
don't got a way to
stay and they were like okay well you
can go stay over here
i was in like three different shelters
but the last one i ended up in
was like the the nicest one which isn't
wasn't really saying much but it was it
was over here in hollywood on sunset
and i lived there for two years did you
really yeah you lived in a va shelter
for two years while you were doing
stand-up yep holy [ __ ] dude
yep and i and and and uh
did any of them come see you
nope oh uh well yeah yeah one of you
should have done a show at the shelter
man no see that was the thing too is i
didn't want
comics knowing
why
i don't know why at the time i don't
know why i gave a [ __ ] so much were you
embarrassed i think i was i think i was
a little
embarrassed but it was but it was more
like
i don't want nobody to see my weakness i
hear you on me man that's a strength to
me your [ __ ] you got these [ __ ] guys
bitching about their ubers and their
condos and everything else in the rain
and you're in a [ __ ] shelter getting
out there
my big challenge was that and now you're
on netflix
and the honeydew and the honeydew i mean
come on go
no my big challenge was getting them the
damn
because you got it because there's
levels of privilege in the shelter you
know level one two three and and and and
to get the next level from level because
level one is just you just after you've
been there for so long level two is like
you have a job
and to get them to respect stand up as a
job i had to do all this extra [ __ ] like
i had to take extra tests extra like
breathalyzers and urinalysis
other [ __ ] so for the whole time i
wasn't smoking or drinking and i had um
and then and then
and then i got the job at the comedy
store as the door guy
and so they completely got off my back
about it you know me and then six months
later i got fired
from the from the store from the store
so then what they got back on you well
they kind of got back on me but then
um you know a bunch of [ __ ] happened in
the in the in the interim where the guy
the guy that was running the place he
ended up
relapsing
so the guy that was running the place
ended up like doing some of the drugs he
had confiscated from somebody i guess
yeah maybe he confiscated something from
somebody he was like oh this is my drug
you know i mean he and it wasn't even
like a it wasn't like an investigation
and i'm like this [ __ ] came to
work one day
and if you if you if you've ever been an
addict because that's the thing some of
the people in their addicts you know and
if you've ever been an addict you know
when you see a muffin on your [ __ ] you
know and he just came to work just
obviously just like a whole different
person bro it's a whole different person
like all disheveled and [ __ ] and then
and then they and then they found out
that like a whole bunch of the money
that was supposed to be being spent
wasn't actually
that's what i'm trying to tell you
before we started like
the a lot of the times these programs
that's for the homeless people it's just
it's just a prop for profit
and and millions of dollars are getting
funneled to people that they're not
spending it on the home they're just
taking that [ __ ] yeah
and that's what was happening today
because all of a sudden out of the blue
out of this [ __ ] got caught
all of a sudden out of the blue we got
new beds to do mattresses they brought
in the daggone
um
what you calling people that kill bugs
exterminator yeah all of a sudden the
you should have had that back in the day
yeah all of a sudden the dagger on uh
food improve man what a [ __ ] story
dude good for you
all right so i want to say this because
we're wrapping up here and i thank you
for coming on and opening up about all
this but i didn't tell you this uh i ask
sometimes i forget but i asked guests
their first time on um what advice you
would give to your 16 year old self and
that
is a pivotal age for you obviously so
knowing what everything we just talked
about if you can go back and tell
16 year old you something what would you
say
[ __ ] them all you're right
yeah you're right you were right the
whole time
um
listen if that's what it is it can be
that i don't know man i guess yeah i
guess that this would be what it is
be true to yourself stay you oh yeah
that would be it yeah be be true to
yourself yeah that was a thing that you
struggled with be true to yourself yeah
well one more time um please promote
everything you'd like to promote
definitely your netflix special all that
yeah netflix special
um what's your website again where then
you'll see your date season three of the
stand-ups you go to my link tree off of
any of my socials bs comedian or you can
go to um
uh brian simpson comedy.com
and then and see any of my tour dates or
festival dates all right man well thank
you again for coming on
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you